Je vous invite à lire vos bibles dans les livres d'Actes, chapitre 6.
J'aimerais demander à tous les aient la Bible verte.
On va lire du verset 1 à 7.
Actes 6, 1 à 7.
Donc, on aille tous la Bible verte pour faire la lecture.
En ce temps-là, le nombre des disciples augmentant,
les hélénistes murmurèrent contre les éboueurs,
parce que leurs vœux étaient négligés,
la distribution se faisait chaque jour.
Les douze convoquèrent la multitude et le biblique de plaisir.
Il n'est pas convenable que nous laissions la parole de Dieu pour servir au tableau.
C'est pourquoi, frères, je laisse parmi vous sept hommes,
de qui l'on rend un bon témoignage,
soit plein d'esprits sains et de sagesse,
et que nous nous chargerons de cet emploi.
Et nous, nous continuerons à nous appliquer à la cagère et au ministère de la parole.
Cette proposition, plus à toute l'Assemblée,
ils élurent et tiennent, hommes pleins de foi et d'esprit sain.
Amen.
Prions ensemble.
Seigneur, nous voulons te remercier pour les privilèges que tu nous donnes
de commencer une nouvelle saison,
qui est très importante pour la vie de l'Église Bonne Nouvelle.
Nous te sommes reconnaissants, Seigneur,
pour la beauté qu'il y a à ton Église,
parce qu'elle se présente de manière conformée à tes écritures,
et par les processus, Seigneur, de ces lavages,
de ces embellissements que tu promets de faire
dans nos vies, dans la vie de ta communauté, Seigneur,
par ta parole.
Nous te remercions, Seigneur,
de voir comment l'Église, dans sa jeunesse,
a expérimenté une croissance,
et elle a pu, Seigneur, sous l'influence de ton Saint-Esprit,
sous la direction de tes apôtres, Seigneur,
s'organiser
devant ce que le Saint-Esprit était en train de faire.
Nous voulons, Seigneur,
que cette mémorialité soit expérimentée par notre Église.
Nous te remercions,
car par ta grâce,
tu as permis
à cette Église de grandir.
Tu as, par ta grâce, Seigneur,
honoré
les efforts
qui ta grâce même
a soutenu
pendant les années, Seigneur,
lorsqu'on s'aimait,
lorsqu'on travaillait,
lorsqu'on endurait,
et c'est avec joie, Seigneur,
que nous célébrons la croissance de cette Église.
Nous te remercions,
car tu nous as pourvus
des enseignants fidèles
de ta parole.
Tu nous as pourvus, Seigneur,
des membres fidèles,
responsables,
au sein de cette Église.
Et nous sommes sûrs, Seigneur,
que tu nous pourvois aussi, Seigneur,
des diacres, Seigneur,
pour servir au sein de cette Église.
Ils sont déjà là, Seigneur,
comme ils étaient déjà là,
mais nous arrivons au moment
où nous devons les identifier.
Et pour les faire, nous,
ton Église,
nous devons les faire
de manière informée,
de manière dirigée par ta parole.
Et nous te supplions, Seigneur,
que nous puissions traverser cette phase
de la manière la plus instruite possible,
la plus responsable possible.
Nous te supplions
que cette Église ne soit pas distraite
par des travaux secondaires,
par une dynamique mondaine
de voir les choses,
une gestion d'entrepreneurs,
Seigneur,
envers ton Église,
et s'effier à des méthodes de croissance
ou des organisations
par des superstructures.
et nous voulons tout simplement
faire confiance
à la simplicité
de la structure
que nous trouvons dans ta parole,
faire confiance non seulement
au fait que ta puissance
va sauver et édifier les perdus,
mais que ta puissance aussi
va pourvoir non seulement la fin,
mais aussi les moyens,
les méthodes.
Et nous te supplions
que cette Église soit conforme
à la structure légère
que ta Bible présente.
Pour la gloire de ton homme,
nous te supplions
que tu puisses venir
non seulement nos études,
mais aussi, Seigneur,
la réalité de ce que tu bâtis
est faite à travers ta parole,
ta parole créatrice,
ta parole transformatrice,
et donc que ta parole
soit en train de construire
dans nos cœurs, Seigneur,
dans notre Église
et ministère des diacres.
Au nom de Jésus, Seigneur.
Amen.
Donc nous voici
traverser
un nouveau cycle
d'études bibliques.
Donc avant de passer
proprement à l'étude,
nous allons baser
la plupart des leçons
sur ces livres-là.
Voilà pourquoi
on a quelques copies
pour ceux qui voulaient
raccompagner.
On vous encourage
très fort à les faire.
Comme je vous ai dit,
c'est une responsabilité
de toute la communauté,
de tous les membres
de participer
à l'identification
et à la confirmation
des diacres,
tout comme vous avez participé
aussi pour
l'identification
et la confirmation
des anciens
qui ont été ordonnés.
Et pour savoir
identifier un diacre
selon la Bible,
il faut apprendre
avec la Bible
ce qui est un diacre.
Je pense que ça va être
surprenant pour la majorité
d'entre nous
de voir comment
on est plus habitué
avec des conceptions
ou des traditions
différentes d'Église
de ce qui est un diacre,
parfois à une échelle
pour devenir ancien
ou pasteur.
Mais c'est très important
de saisir
de la conception biblique.
Donc ça va être
un cours
que je ne vais pas faire
toute seule,
je ne vais pas vous donner
les cours toute seule
car je serai aussi responsable
du cours des membres
qui aura lieu.
Donc l'équipe pastorale
sera engagée,
on va faire en rotation,
les livres nous servira
des bases
et comme il est beaucoup
plus concentré
sur les ministères
des diacres
en soi-même,
même s'il va porter
un enseignement similaire
à ce que je vais vous apporter
aujourd'hui dans cette
laissante introductoire
qui va être plutôt
une exposition biblique.
Nous allons remarquer
par la lecture de texte
qu'on a vue
qu'il y a
une raison
qui est centrale
pour l'institution
des diacres
et elle a à voir
avec les rôles
prééminents
et la tâche prééminente
de l'enseignement
de la parole de Dieu.
Donc c'est quelque part
pour dégager,
pour libérer
ceux qui sont chargés
de l'enseignement
de la parole
et de la prière
qu'est les rôles
des diacres à lieu.
Et nous n'allons jamais
savoir combien chérir
les rôles des diacres
si on n'a pas appris
à comprendre
et à chérir
les rôles
des hommes des dieux
qui peuvent se libérer
pour se consacrer
pleinement
à l'enseignement
de la parole
et de la prière.
Donc ça va être
plus ou moins
l'une des choses
centrales
que nous allons voir
aujourd'hui.
Nous allons revenir
sur les textes
et marcher
étape par étape
dans ces textes-là.
Et donc,
c'est une nouvelle phase
pour nous
en tant qu'Église.
Il faut qu'on soit
constamment dans la prière
pour que nous ne soyons pas
dans les transferts
d'informations
tout simplement
mais que nous puissions
saisir
ce qui est la responsabilité
de la communauté.
et donc,
c'est impossible
d'accomplir
ces tâches
sans l'instruction
biblique.
Donc,
la grande question
que nous trouvons ici
dans ces passages,
c'est une Église
qui commence
à s'organiser
d'une manière
un peu plus formelle.
OK ?
Il y a au moins
deux abordages
vers ces passages.
Certains qui vont considérer
comme si
l'Église était tout simplement
en train de s'organiser
mais que
ce qui se passe
avec ces sept hommes
qui sont choisis
n'est pas forcément
l'institution formelle
des diacres,
encore,
car il y a d'autres passages
où l'institution formelle
des diacres
a plus de clarté
comme par exemple
1 Timothée chapitre 3
ce sont des mentions
très formelles
des diacres.
Ici,
donc,
certains pensent
que comme
le terme diacre
n'est pas utilisé
comme en substantif,
il est plutôt utilisé
comme verbe
ceux qui peuvent servir
et qui disent aussi
que les anciens
ou les apôtres plutôt
vont servir
les ministères de la parole.
c'est un espace
des diakoniens
et la même chose
par rapport à ceux
qui vont servir
aux tables.
C'est ce qu'on a lu
dans les textes.
Donc,
pour certains,
ce n'est pas forcément
l'institution formelle
et une des raisons
pour laquelle
ces personnes
marchent
dans cette direction,
c'est
car ils comprennent
qu'à partir
des premiers
Timothée 3,
c'est clair
pour eux,
c'est une possibilité,
je ne veux pas rentrer
encore dans ces débats,
mais c'est clair pour eux
que les femmes
sont aussi diacres.
et ici,
l'expression claire
qu'ils choisissent
cet homme
fait que pour eux,
ce ne soit pas encore
l'institution formelle
des diacres,
mais c'est une solution
pour ces moments.
Moi,
je ne partage pas
cette vision du texte
et je pense
que le fait
qu'ils aient choisi
cet homme
peut avoir
d'autres explications,
même si on croit
que les femmes
puissent être diacres,
car la situation
était telle
qu'il s'était plus
approprié aux hommes
de prendre
la résolution
de ces problèmes
spécifiques
qu'aux femmes,
car il y avait
une dispute
non seulement
entre les femmes,
mais il y avait
aussi une division
qui a engagé
les deux groupes
des peuples.
Donc là,
on va comprendre
tout ça
avec les temps
au fur et à mesure.
Ce n'est pas mon objectif
aujourd'hui,
à un moment donné,
on va traiter
cette possibilité
que les femmes
soient diacres
ou non.
Notre Église
va devoir prendre
une décision
et on arrivera.
Pour l'instant,
je voulais tout simplement
considérer
ce qui,
pour moi,
est véritablement
la naissance
officielle
des diacres,
car je vois
plusieurs niveaux,
plusieurs évidences
des formalités.
L'Assemblée
est convoquée,
l'Assemblée
va devoir nominer,
va devoir élire
et il y aura
une ordination
de ces hommes-là
pour cet office
qui est l'office
du service.
Et donc,
à mon avis,
c'est véritablement
la jeunesse
du service des diacres
et devant lesquelles
nous sommes ici.
Mais ce qui est certain,
indépendamment
des positions,
c'est que ce texte
est l'une des bases
bibliques
les plus importantes
pour qu'on ait
aucun doute
du fait
que l'Église
n'est pas
qu'il y ait
tout simplement
un organisme.
et l'Église
elle est aussi
une organisation.
C'est un cas
pour l'organisation
biblique
car
ce qui nous voit ici
c'est qu'à partir
de certains facteurs
qui ont rendu
les travaux
de l'Église
un peu plus difficiles,
l'Église a dû
s'organiser.
Il y a des points
très positifs
qui ont rendu
les travaux
plus difficiles,
il y a des points
très négatifs
qui ont rendu
les travaux
plus difficiles
et la réalité
c'est que ça
a donné l'occasion
à l'Église
de s'organiser
et l'enregistrement
biblique
est pour
cette organisation.
Donc aujourd'hui
nous sommes en train
de vivre
un débat
qui est
à l'opposé
non seulement
de la Bible
mais à l'opposé
même de la raison
et de la nature.
Ce sont ceux
qui veulent réclamer
que l'Église
est un organisme
mais pas une organisation.
Donc on veut vivre
la vie de l'Église
sans vivre
l'institution de l'Église,
l'engagement de l'Église,
sans vivre la notion
d'adhésion
à la notion
des membres,
la notion
des rédivabilités
mutuelles,
cette notion
des liens formels
entre les membres
d'une Église
et notamment
qui veulent mépriser
l'aspect
que l'Église
est une institution
divine.
Donc pour ces personnes,
ils vont souvient
par exemple
qu'ils nous sommes
tous membres
de l'Église
et majuscule
spirituelle
dans ces circonstances.
Tous les chrétiens
les sont
membres
de cette Église
invisible
mais l'expression
de cette Église
invisible
est toujours
une expression
locale.
Et la Bible
elle est claire
par rapport
à cette réalité.
Et donc ici
nous voyons comment
cette organisation
est importante.
Et tous les organismes
ont aussi
une organisation.
Il n'y a pas
un organisme
qui ne soit pas
organisé.
tous les êtres
vivants
ont une espèce
de structure
sans laquelle
elles ne peuvent pas
exister.
Et c'est clair
que cette structure
est à service
de la vie.
C'est pour rendre
la vie possible.
C'est clair
que le plus important
c'est l'aspect
vital.
Mais sans organisation,
sans ordre,
sans structure,
la vie
n'est pas possible.
Et donc la réalité
c'est que l'Église
elle est
les deux choses.
Les deux extrêmes
qu'on a
ce sont
ceux qui veulent
tellement s'effier
aux structures
qu'ils font
de l'Église
une super institution
ou super structure
et qui finissent
pour étouffer
ou cacher
même la vie.
Et la réalité
c'est que
ce n'est pas
la bonne manière
d'interpréter
cette question biblique.
Une chose
qu'on va remarquer ici
c'est que l'Église
va quelque part
réagir
à un développement
naturel
qu'il est
Saint-Esprit
est en train
d'apporter,
une croissance
de l'Église
et l'Église
va s'adapter
à ce que
le Saint-Esprit
est en train
de faire.
Et l'Église
va s'adapter
à ce que
le Saint-Esprit
est en train
de faire
en contemplant
ce que
le Saint-Esprit
a déjà
pourvu
au sein de l'Église
des personnes
capables
pour occuper
l'office
des diagres.
Et donc
ce n'est pas
la meilleure manière
de penser à l'Église
d'avoir
une superstructure
dès le départ,
d'avoir des rêves
de remplir
tous les départements,
d'avoir un agenda
très lourd
et de chercher
à forcer
les personnes
à rentrer
dans les cases.
La réalité
c'est qu'il y a
un processus
de vie naturel
qui se développe
et bien sûr
qu'il y a
quelques cases
qui sont importantes
et bibliques
pour que l'Église
vive,
comme par exemple
les diacres
et les anciens,
sauf que
nous devons
reconnaître
que ces fonctions
sont des appels,
des vocations.
Ce n'est pas à nous
de former,
ce n'est pas à nous
de faire entrer,
c'est à nous
tout simplement
d'identifier
qui sont les personnes
qui Dieu a pourvues,
qui Dieu a élevées.
Et donc la réalité
c'est que nous ne pouvons
ni être dans l'extrême
de ceux qui ont abusé
des structures
et de l'autorité
mal placées
et qui ont fait
qu'une autre extrême
soit très présente
dans nos jours
qui ce sont ces personnes
déçues avec les Églises,
les institutions
et qui vont rejeter
complètement ce qui est
biblique.
Et donc la position
la plus équilibrée
est toujours
la position biblique.
La mauvaise expérience
ne justifie jamais
l'abandon
de ce qui est biblique.
Et nous allons apprendre
en fait que si
on aurait mieux fait
notre travail
responsable
en tant qu'il est
membre d'Église,
on serait capable
d'identifier
des vrais
appelés
au ministère pastoral,
des vrais
appelés
à être diacre,
quelle est la fonction
d'un diacre,
d'un pasteur
et qu'est-ce
qu'il y a
d'Église légitime.
Si on avait exercé
ces fonctions,
on serait moins déçu.
On allait vivre
moins des traumas
avec les Églises.
Et donc ici,
nous avons
ces deux propositions
mais la réalité
c'est que l'enseignement
biblique,
l'enseignement
de la réalité
est que Dieu
est un Dieu
organisé
et que tous les organismes
qui Dieu a créés
sont une organisation.
Donc la réalité
c'est que quand on
contemple l'Epsombe 19,
l'Epsombe 104,
le fait que Dieu
appelle les étoiles
par nom
ou que chaque cheveu
de nos têtes
soit compté,
on voit plusieurs
psaumes
qui pointent envers
cette organisation
éclatante
de la sagesté
de Dieu
dans l'univers.
Dieu n'est pas
qu'un organisme
qui exerce
une influence
subjective,
intuitive
et c'est fini.
Le soleil
est là
tous les jours
à la bonne heure.
Et donc la réalité
c'est qu'il y a
un ordre
évident
quand on contemple
la création.
Nos vies personnelles,
le fonctionnement
de nos corps,
nous ne pouvons qu'être
en vie
car nous sommes
très bien organisés.
La parole
nous démontre
de manière très claire
que Dieu a un plan,
il a planifié
les choses
avant de créer,
il a décrété
les choses,
il gouverne
il a fixé
des temps
pour opérer
un grand salut
qui est très organisé.
Et quand on contemple
non seulement
ces plans
de rédemption
des dieux
mais qui nous contemplons
aussi
les aspects spécifiques
de la parole des dieux
comme par exemple
comment construire
les temples,
les tabernacles,
les dix commandements,
toutes les lois civiques,
etc.
On voit combien Dieu
est un Dieu d'ordre,
un Dieu organisé.
Quand on considère
par exemple
que même dans
les Nouveaux Testaments
en arrivant
à 1 Timothée 3
lorsqu'on va voir
les qualifications,
les recommandations
pour les anciens
et pour les diacres,
à la fin,
Paul va dire
c'est pour que
dans mon absence
tu saches
comment procéder
dans la maison
des dieux.
Donc c'est pas
à nous tout simplement
d'inventer l'église,
de vivre l'église
à notre manière,
d'organiser l'église
de gouverner
l'église à notre manière.
La Bible,
elle nous a laissé,
Dieu nous a laissé
dans sa parole
des consignes,
des instructions
très claires.
Malheureusement,
on cherche
à réinventer
les poudres
et on essaye
de faire
quelque chose
de nouveau
sans avoir
conscience
et faire confiance
à ce que Dieu
a déjà donné
comme moyen
d'organiser l'église.
Donc on doit faire attention
car l'église
elle est
véritablement
organique.
Nous sommes en train de voir
en acte 6,
l'église grandit
et maintenant
elle doit
s'organiser,
s'équiper.
Donc quand on voit
un éphésien chapitre 4
qui nous présente
l'église comme
les corps du Christ,
c'est l'image
de quelque chose
de très ironique,
la connexion
de tous les membres
de ces corps.
Sauf que nous sommes
un membre,
un corps
qui est formé
par des membres
dont la croissance,
attention,
n'aura lieu
qu'est,
voilà,
qu'est-ce qu'il va dire
Paul aux éphésiens,
lorsqu'ils les membres
bien coordonnés
peuvent tirer
la croissance
et grandir
dans la maturité
du Christ.
Donc c'est cette
coordination,
c'est cette conscience
de quelle est ma fonction
dans ces corps
car même si
les anciens
sont chargés
d'équiper
les membres,
nous avons
un nombre
infini
des ministères
à travers lesquels
chaque chrétien
a reçu des dons
et des vocations
pour s'édifier
mutuellement,
pour nous édifier
mutuellement.
Donc c'est
aux anciens
de vous équiper
par la parole
mais c'est à vous
de jouer vos rôles
pour l'édification
mutuelle.
Il y a certaines choses
qui séparent
aux anciens
des fers
comme par exemple
la réconciliation
entre cette division
pour plus que
les anciens
doivent être
prédisposés
à jouer un rôle
dans la réconciliation
de certaines personnes
comme même
l'apôtre Paul
va les faire
c'est même
par l'occupation
principale
des anciens.
Ici
les diacres
vont être chargés
d'une telle fonction
aussi.
Donc c'est très intéressant
de voir
comme Dieu
a choisi
les anciens
pour s'occuper
de quelque chose
qui est principal
et les diacres
vont apparaître
du milieu
de la congrégation
pour libérer
les anciens
pour qu'ils puissent
accomplir
leur tâche principale.
Donc
l'église
est un organisme
mais aussi
une institution.
dans ces passages
nous voyons
qu'il y a
une espèce
de convocation
d'une assemblée
il y a
un ordre
pour nommer
pour élire
pour ordonner
il y a
des positions
d'autorité
il y a
des positions
de soumission
il y a aussi
dans ces passages
ou dans d'autres passages
d'actes
des indices
qu'on avait
des listes
des veuves
des membres
on était en train
de compter
combien de personnes
étaient rajoutées
à l'église
ici nous arrivons
si on fait bien
les comptes
par rapport
au récit
de la progression
en actes
on est autour
des vents
à 30 000 personnes
déjà
des 120
qui ont commencé
on est déjà
autour
des 30 000 personnes
une croissance
énorme de l'église
et donc ici
nous sommes devant
cet organisme
cette vie
qui est poussée
par le Saint-Esprit
mais qui doit
s'adapter
et s'organiser
et donc
selon les paramètres
des écritures
nous avons
une église
ordonnée
lorsqu'il nous
a
l'office
d'ancien
et l'office
des diacres
l'office
des pasteurs
et l'office
des diacres
ordonnés
office
qui sont là
donc reconnus
par la communauté
et qui sont mis en place
et donc
pour plus qu'on ait
un nombre
infini
des ministères
que vous allez
tous jouer
à l'église
nous avons
deux rôles
qui sont des rôles
officiels
reconnus
dans la parole
des dieux
et qui sont importants
pour l'église
donc ici
nous sommes devant
les cas par excellence
pour l'organisation
de l'église
et nous allons commencer
par la considération
du cas
on va étudier
ces cas
qu'est-ce qui a fait
que cette église
marche envers
l'institution des diacres
cette organisation
ils ont à nouveau
les premiers versets
acte 6
verset
pardon
oui
acte 6
verset 1
en ces temps-là
le nombre
des disciples
augmentant
donc premier élément
croissance
c'est ça qui fait
que le travail
d'une église
devient plus difficile
c'est la croissance
les anciens
sont là
et tant que l'église
soit encore petite
c'est encore
un peu plus facile
de donner
une attention
un peu plus spéciale
c'est comme pour les enfants
les plus enfants on a
les plus on doit être
discipliné
pour donner
l'attention de Dieu
pour juger
qui a vraiment
besoin d'attention
et jouer
ces rôles-là
quelles sont les tâches
que nous n'avons pas
besoin de faire
que d'autres peuvent faire
à notre place
il y a une croissance
et ce n'est pas
une croissance petite ici
il y a un nombre
énorme de choses
qui vont s'impliquer
lorsqu'une église
va grandir
de cette manière
où sera l'espace
où on va se rencontrer
donc bien sûr
on est loin
d'être dans des challenges
d'avoir 20 000 personnes
mais c'est déjà un challenge
dans l'agenda du pasteur
de s'occuper
même des négociations
des visites
et ces autres choses
et donc bien sûr
que là
on a encore le temps
de les faire
mais plutôt
on peut dégager
ce type de préoccupation
et bon
d'autres affaires
dans l'ensemble
de la communauté
indépendant de comment
l'église elle marche
il y a un nombre
infini en fait
des responsabilités
qui sont les résultats
sont les résultats
tout simplement
de la croissance
de l'église
c'est une bonne chose
bien sûr
la croissance
mais ça implique
beaucoup plus de travail
sauf que les travails
les plus efficaces
que les anciens vont faire
c'est le même travail
qui a engendré
cette croissance
c'est de continuer
à les enseigner
la parole
et à prier pour eux
vous comprenez ?
on va y arriver
et donc
les nombres
des disciples
augmentables
donc les premiers
défis
qui réclamaient
une meilleure organisation
c'est la croissance
la deuxième
c'était un conflit
et quels étaient
les conflits ?
c'est ici
dans les cas
les hélénistes
murmuraient
contre les hébreux
donc là
c'est pas très clair
qui a eu tort
ok
les faits
constatés
c'est que leurs veuves
avaient été négligés
dans la distribution
qui se faisait
chaque jour
on sait pas
si cette murmuration
était tout simplement
des murmurations
superficielles
triviales
la dispute
car il y avait déjà
une tension
entre ces deux groupes
des personnes
c'était des juifs
ok
qui étaient rentrés
dans la dispersion
et des juifs
qui étaient toujours
restés dans
sur place
et qui se sentaient
plus légitimes
que les autres
qui étaient un peu
mélangés avec
d'autres peuples
et donc la réalité
c'est qu'il y a
une division
comme si certains
se sentaient plus
importants que les autres
et les problèmes
c'est que si
cette division
si cette négligence
était quelque chose
d'important
réellement
on sait pas
combien ça a manqué
si elles étaient
en train de réclamer
par caprice
mais la réalité
c'est qu'il y avait
déjà une motivation
derrière
cette division
qui pouvait
engendrer
cette dispute
et en plus de ça
il y avait aussi
cette tension
derrière
que si
cette distribution
était injuste
de manière importante
ça allait
amplifier
la difficulté
et donc
ce sont
les disputes
qu'on voit
arriver au sein de l'église
et qui
demandent
une énergie
énorme
qui est
ce qui pourrait
être occupé
de l'enseignement
de l'ensemble
de la proclamation
pour l'évangélisation
du dehors
soit en train
de dépenser
leur énergie
envers la réconciliation
des membres
de la communauté
donc on voit
comment
même l'apôtre Paul
emprisonné
va écrire
pour promouvoir
la réconciliation
entre deux sœurs
qui étaient en train
de se disputer
et donc c'est énorme
de voir son cœur
préoccupé
et donc c'est pas
que les apôtres
ne veulent pas
s'occuper de ces choses
car la réconciliation
bienheureuse
ceux qui procurent
la paix
ils seront appelés
fils des dieux
mais la réalité
c'est qu'ils s'étaient
un problème
qui aurait pu être réglé
par d'autres personnes
et donc il y a des conflits
qui ont réclamé
et des conflits
qui étaient très pratiques
c'était vraiment
de distribuer
dans l'autre
c'est une bonne chose
l'église s'immobilise
on fait des dons
et on va chercher
à bénir ces personnes
qui sont dans les besoins
et donc c'est quelque chose
de très bien
sauf que c'est pas
la chose principale
que l'église doit faire
d'autres personnes
qui sont les anciens
peuvent les faire
d'autres membres
on ne devrait pas être
tous les temps
en attente
pour considérer
mon pasteur
comme quelqu'un
de plus spirituel
il devrait être
plus engagé
dans les oeuvres sociales
donc bien sûr
qu'une église
devrait toujours
être sensible
aux besoins
car c'est quelque chose
que l'église faisait ici
donc on n'a pas
comment effacer
sauf que nous ne pouvons
jamais oublier
que la seule chose
exclusive à l'église
que nous pouvons faire
et que nous devons faire
c'est de prêcher l'évangile
ces autres travaux
il y a beaucoup
d'organisations
et d'organismes
dans la société
qui peuvent les faire
mais
pour ce qui concerne
la proclamation
de l'évangile
c'est que l'église
qui peut les faire
et donc
il y a donc
une croissance
il y a un conflit
et donc il y a
une surcharge
qui fait
que les disciples
disent
au verset 2
les apôtres disent
il n'est pas
convenable
qu'ils nous laissons
la parole des dieux
pour servir
aux tables
il n'est pas
agréable
et donc là
ils sont arrivés
à la conclusion
qu'il fallait
faire cette différence
entre
ce qui est notre charge
et ce qui ne peut pas
devenir
une surcharge
ce n'était pas
convenable
de tourner
les dos
envers la parole
et donc
là
on passe
à une autre observation
dans les textes
on a vu
les cas
ou les problèmes
et on doit être
sensible
à la bataille
ce rituel
car
même si Satan
est détrôné
dès que les Christ
a accompli
son oeuvre
à la croix
il n'est pas
complètement inactif
il est très actif
dans la bataille
s'il ne peut pas
nous perdre
ou nous faire perdre
les saluts
il peut
distraire l'église
enlever
ce qu'il y a
des plus puissants
de l'église
et lorsqu'il les fait
l'église
commence à perdre
sa capacité
d'enfance
d'agendre
fruit
car nos âmes
sont spirituelles
et la réalité
c'est que
les problèmes
qui sont apparus
à l'église
les plus dangereux
étaient la distraction
car
Satan
il a toujours travaillé
avec plusieurs armes
différentes
quand on voit
les livres d'actes
c'est surtout
la persécution
et à plusieurs reprises
on va devoir
lutter
contre les membres
de l'église
qui sont découragés
à cause des persécutions
à cause de la pression
du monde
à la pression des collègues
au travail
à l'université
etc.
ce qui ne devrait pas
être le cas
quand on voit comment
l'église a prié
en acte chapitre 4
sous une persécution
infiniment plus lourde
que celle qu'on traverse
et les saints esprits
sont venus
les fortifier
pour avoir du courage
pour proclamer la parole
et donc
qu'est-ce que l'église
doit faire ?
proclamer la parole
en prière
et qu'est-ce que
Satan veut faire ?
nous faire peur
par la persécution
par les pressions culturelles
ensuite
on peut penser aussi
au problème
du péché
engendrer des tentations
pour que l'église
même si elle est déjà
libre
de la domination du péché
elle oublie son identité
elle ne soit plus
en train de se nourrir
de la parole
et en train de prier
et elle commence
à s'adapter au monde
à nouveau
et à partir de là
l'église
elle perd sa force
d'évangélisation
par les péchés
très abîmés
très découragés
Satan
il va aussi produire
des hérésies
au sein de l'église
et
il est
expert
à engendrer
des divisions
dans les corps du Christ
là où Christ
a uni
tous
dans son propre corps
il arrive
à conduire
les membres
de l'église
à se disputer
ce qui est
un travail
satanique
car le travail
du Saint-Esprit
est le travail
de la réconciliation
avec Dieu
et entre nous
et donc
cette stratégie
de Satan
elle est très efficace
pour enlever
la capacité
de l'église
de porter
un bon témoignage
et dans
la vie chrétienne
dans la promotion
de l'église
il n'y a aucun
progrès
sans bataille
il n'y a aucune
victoire
sans combat
il n'y a aucun
pas
dans la sanctification
sans discipline
sans transpiration
et la réalité
c'est que
ça va nous faire
réjouir davantage
c'est intéressant
car à la fin
les textes
vont nous démontrer
comment l'église
va grandir
encore plus
mais la réalité
c'est que ces problèmes
là étaient nécessaires
c'était une bataille
et c'était intéressant
de voir comment
l'église a réagi
elle a trouvé
la bonne solution
mais les plus grands dangers
ici
étaient la distraction
car
les problèmes
vont apparaître
la croissance
est naturelle
si nous sommes
une église légitime
sauf que
on doit faire attention
à ne pas réagir
aux défis
et aux challenges
avec une mentalité
mondaine
humaine
et donc
ce que Satan
a cherché à faire
par cette occasion
c'était
d'enlever
des postes
les plus pertinents
!
les personnes
qui Dieu avait choisi
pour faire promouvoir
son église
à travers la parole
!
Il a voulu
quitter
de l'église
ses armes
les plus puissantes
la prière
et l'enseignement
biblique
Paul
nous enseigne
que la bataille
n'est pas
contre la chair
ni contre les sang
mais contre les principautés
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
quelque part
combien spirituel
est la tâche
des diacres
pendant qu'ils sont là
en train de servir aux tables
en train de raccolter
des offrandes
pour administrer
ces offrandes
à fond des pouvoirs
aux besoins de l'église
pendant qu'ils vont régler
les problèmes
des sonos
des vidéos
la lumière
ou la cuisine
c'est très spirituel
car ils ne sont pas
en train de quitter
ceux qui Dieu a appelé
pour se consacrer
à la parole
et à la prière
de faire leur travail
c'est intéressant
j'étais dans un entretien
pastoral
cette semaine
et c'est un couple
qui vient
d'un autre pays
et qui doit encore
apprendre la langue
et après notre discussion
c'est qu'il
les maris
il a dit
aujourd'hui
je suis convaincu
que la chose
la plus spirituelle
que je puisse faire
aujourd'hui
c'est d'apprendre
les français
et c'est une réalité
la chose la plus spirituelle
que l'église
aurait pu faire
à ces moments là
c'était
que ceux qui se chargent
de ces problèmes
pratiques
dans la vie de l'église
ne soient pas
les anciens
ceux qui étaient chargés
principalement
de la prière
et de la parole
de Dieu
nous apprenons
à chérir
l'aspect
spirituel
de la tâche
des diacres
quand on considère
ce qu'ils ont
préservé
de ce qu'il y a
de plus important
dans la vie
d'une église
un ministère
solide
des proclamations
de la parole
concentrées
sur la prière
car sans ça
nous ne pouvons
rien faire
et donc
ils ont eu
quatrième
observation
sur les textes
un discernement
spirituel
ils se sont
focalisés
sur une solution
spirituelle
c'est intéressant
à remarquer
parce qu'ils disent
il n'est pas
convenable
que nous laissions
la parole
de Dieu
pour servir
au table
ils ne sont pas
en train
de diminuer
l'importance
de servir au table
là
il y a
un aspect
comparatif
ce n'est pas
qu'ils ne soient
pas disposés
à servir
car les services
des apôtres
et les services
des anciens
du pasteur
c'est les services
quelque part
les plus
exposés
à les spectacles
terme biblique
et quand ils disent ça
c'est les spectacles
de l'époque
c'était quand on lançait
les hommes
pour être
pour faire les défis
contre les lions
dans les arénas
et donc la réalité
c'est que
la manière
dont on voit
les apôtres
souffrir
la persécution
la manière
dont ils sont
exposés
c'est qu'eux
ils sont en train
de vivre
une espèce
de service
de renoncement
de porter une croix
et de s'annuler
quelque part
dans leur vie
pour se consacrer
continuellement
à la proclamation
de la parole
en s'exposant
aux pires persécutions
car ils vont devenir
s'ils sont
suffisamment fidèles
à la parole
des dieux
tous ceux qui veulent
mener une vie pieuse
seront persécutés
et donc les premiers
persécutés
notamment
seront
les plus ciblés
quelque part
par l'enfer
seront
ceux qui sont
dans la vangarde
de la proclamation
de l'évangile
ça a été toujours
comme ça
ça sera toujours
et donc quand on va
lorsque Paul dit
et qu'il décrit
tout ce qu'il a souffert
et qu'il dit
je porte mon corps
les marques
du Christ
c'est par là
qu'on comprend en fait
que ce n'est pas
des personnes
qui avaient peur
de servir
au contraire
ils ont été appelés
par les Christ
pour faire les services
du plus grand esclave
d'annuler leur vie
pour la promotion
de la vie spirituelle
des autres
et la réalité
c'est que quand on voit
les lave-pieds
ce qu'ils ont fait
et qu'ils ont aussi
été engagés
à plusieurs reprises
dans des oeuvres pareilles
à celle-ci
sauf qu'ils ont appris
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
dévendre
l'opportunité
de faire avancer
les royaumes
et l'importance
d'être bien équipé
l'église
par la parole
des dieux
et par la prière
ils ne pouvaient pas
perdre du temps
avec une tâche
que d'autres
pourraient accomplir
vous comprenez ?
et donc la réalité
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
en train de diminuer
l'importance
car ils font quelque chose
d'encore plus humble
et de l'autre côté
ils ont donné
tellement d'importance
à cette affaire
qu'ils ont créé
un office
complètement consacré
à s'occuper
de ces charges
et donc
ils sont là
en train de
voir
ce qui est le plus
convenable
agréable
ce qui est le plus
raisonnable
devant Dieu
surtout
ce ne serait pas
agréable à Dieu
de délaisser la parole
de la prière
pour servir aux tâches
mais aussi
en prenant en considération
les biens de l'église
et donc
ils sont là
en train de faire
la comparaison
entre
la tâche
de servir aux tâches
aux tables
et
cet engagement
continu
auquel
ils étaient appelés
et donc
ils ont eu
du discernement
spirituel
car au lieu
de chercher
d'abord
des solutions
prédominamment
humaines
ils auraient pu
s'asseoir
eux-mêmes
et commencer
à faire
des chartres
et faire
tous les cases
qu'on pourrait imaginer
et séparer
les choses
dans le département
et ils allaient perdre
énormément
de temps
ils pourraient faire
ces travails
d'administration
ils pourraient faire
les travails pratiques
d'aller chercher
de la nourriture
de distribuer
les choses
mais
il y avait
d'autres personnes
qui pouvaient s'occuper
leur mentalité
n'est pas d'aller
dans la direction
de l'interprise
leur mentalité
était
de considérer
c'est une affaire
spirituelle
la vie de l'église
nous allons
perdre
ces combats
si nous délaissons
la parole
nous devons
rester sur notre poste
et chercher
d'autres
et donc
quand on pense
sur une solution
que l'église
aujourd'hui
cherche
distrait par Satan
on voit
quand il pense
à la croissance
de l'église
au lieu de penser
tout simplement
à prêcher Christ
et celui crucifié
et plus rien
on voit
qu'on est en train
de faire confiance
à des superstructures
et des méthodes
de croissance
on est en train
d'étudier
ce que les mondes
aiment le plus
et on est en train
d'adapter
l'église
au goût
du monde
on est en train
de faire confiance
à d'autres méthodes
pour faire l'église
grandir
qui est la prédication
de la parole
et la prière
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que lorsqu'il Lloyd Jones
il a été invité
pour assumer
la première église
à Galles
ils avaient l'habitude
ils avaient
un ministère
des théâtres
à cette église
l'église
comme résultat
du modernisme
elle a perdu
sa confiance
dans la prédication
de la parole
et on a eu
une réduction
du temps
des prédications
et on a eu
la sensation
qu'on avait besoin
de créer
des opportunités
attirantes
pour les non-chrétiens
c'est là
où tous ces ministères
sont apparus
on a commencé
à développer
chaque fois plus
ça a devenu populaire
la notion
du pasteur
à temps partiel
car si la Bible
n'est pas inspirée
on n'a pas besoin
de quelqu'un
qui soit un spécialiste
dans la Bible
avec des sermons
très courts
des ventes
30 minutes
et une église
marquée par plusieurs
activités
et quand Lloyd Jones
arrive à cette église
il voyait
que les personnes
avaient l'habitude
d'à chaque fois
qu'on allait avoir
un ministère
du théâtre
prendre les pupitres
et les déplacer
la première chose
qu'il a fait
c'était de clouer
les pupitres
sur le sol
quand il arrive
à Londres
après
il voit
les mêmes problèmes
il y avait
un estrade
qu'ils avaient monté
et
ce qui n'était
plus en évidence
c'était les pupitres
première décision
on va
enlever l'estrade
il avait l'habitude
de dire
que quand il arrivait
en église
60%
au moins
30%
de personnes
partaient
et un autre phénomène
c'est que plusieurs
personnes
qui étaient
qui sont restées
se convertissaient
après des années
en pensant
qu'ils étaient
des croixants
et ce qu'il a fait
c'était
dans les vins d'estrade
ils ont dit
mais qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire avec les bois
il a dit
l'hiver arrive
on va réchauffer
la cheminée
et donc
prédication
paroles
quand on va
à l'église
pour chercher
les problèmes
des conflits
aujourd'hui
on pense
qu'il faut
que les pastos
soient engagés
et là
ils sont dans
les born out
ils doivent faire
toutes les visitations
tous les conseils
il y a des ministères
qui sont tellement
centrés
sur les conseils
publics
et ça c'est super bien
d'avoir fait
cette migration
après énormément
des années
d'influence
de la psychologie
moderne
dans l'église
de chercher
un psychologue
chrétien
on est revenu
au moins
ou correctement
plutôt
à la pratique
du conseil
biblique
nous allons
conseiller
les chrétiens
par la Bible
sauf qu'il y a
un degré
là aussi
si nous avons
l'attente
qui est la tâche
principale
des pasteurs
soit
les conseils
bibliques
ce qui n'est pas
les cas ici
nous pouvons aussi
enlever
l'étang
des anciens
de ce qui a
une portée
plus large
et plus profonde
les moyens
par excellence
des conseils
de la part
des dieux
des proclamations
et d'enseignements
c'est la prédication
de la parole
c'est les moyens
les plus efficaces
des fois
on va faire
énormément d'entretiens
avec la même personne
et on va percevoir
en fait
que c'est une personne
qui veut
que les pasteurs
remplacent
ce que seulement
Christ peut faire
des fois
elle n'est pas assidue
le dimanche
des fois
elle n'est pas là
en train d'être à jour
dans ses disciplines
des dévotions
elle n'est pas en train
de développer
des relations
avec les membres
de l'église
et là en fait
les pasteurs
ne peuvent pas faire
grande chose
dans une séance
des conseils
et donc la réalité
c'est que oui
ça fait partie
du ministère
pastorale
les conseils bibliques
mais c'est
une partie aussi
que Dieu veut
équiper
toute la communauté
à s'exhorter
mutuellement
à s'édifier
et c'est là
où les choses
sont très importantes
sans donner
trop d'importance
au titre
c'est pas forcément
ceux d'entre nous
qui auraient fait
la formation
qui seraient forcément
les plus équipés
car il y a aussi
la notion
du modèle
mais les études
sont importantes
mais les plus
importants pour nous
c'est de nous plonger
dans les écritures
de prier
et de reproduire
cette édification
mutuelle
par les disciples
mutuels
donc ici
on ne voit pas
dans cette distraction
les désirs
d'être
dans tous les endroits
en même temps
pas préoccupés
avec la sœur
qui était
offensée
car les pasteurs
allaient dans
l'anniversaire
du fils
de quelqu'un d'autre
mais pas
dans l'anniversaire
de son fils
ou qu'il aille
dit bonjour
à une personne
mais il a oublié
par des mille raisons
possibles
qui traversent sa tête
de dire bonjour
à un autre
et donc la réalité
c'est qu'il y a
une distraction
même dans des choses
qui sont bonnes
et légitimes
et donc ils ne vous ont
pas voulu
se laisser surcharger
la réalité
c'est que
les mêmes tâches
attention
qui ont engendré
cette croissance
à l'église
ce sont
les mêmes tâches
qui vont caractériser
la vie du pasteur
il a prié
il a prêché
la bible
il a prié
il a prêché
la bible
il a prié
il a prêché
la bible
il a enseigné
il a conseillé
les personnes
bien sûr
il a formé
des disciples
et c'est exactement
de cette même manière
que les ministères
vont continuer
les personnes
qui sont tombées
dans un péché
sont conduites
à la répentance
par la prédication
les personnes
qui avaient besoin
des conseils
ont été conseillées
par la parole
de Dieu
les transformations
ont eu lieu
par la prière
l'église
agrandie
par la prédication
et par la prière
cette bataille
spirituelle
est une bataille
en continu
avec ces mêmes armes
donc la solution
ne pourrait pas
se dévier
des séquelles spirituelles
inversées
qui pourraient
devenir une stratégie
d'organisation
des méthodes
de croissance
de l'église
donc
une église
structurée
des départements
à remplir
pardon
une église
n'est pas structurée
des départements
à remplir
mais elle est
toujours sensible
à ce qui fait
le Saint-Esprit
et elle s'adapte
à l'installation
d'une structure organisée
donc là
il dit
il n'est pas convenable
que nous laissons
la parole de Dieu
pour servir aux tables
mais
les douze
convoquèrent
la multitude
des disciples
et ils disent
on ne peut pas
délaisser
la parole
frère
choisissez
parmi vous
cet homme
de qui
l'on rende
un bon témoignage
qui soit plein
du Saint-Esprit
et de sagesse
et qui nous chargeront
de cet emploi
donc quelle est
la tâche
principale de l'église
la tâche primaire
de l'église
c'est ce qu'on trouve
dans les versets 4
et nous
nous continuerons
à nous appliquer
à la prière
et au ministère
de la parole
quand on contemple
les actes
des apôtres
ce que nous contemplons
certains ont déjà dit
ce n'est pas forcément
les actes des apôtres
ce sont les actes
du
Saint-Esprit
mais ce qui est
particulièrement
l'acte du Saint-Esprit
d'un acte
c'est quoi exactement
c'est ce qu'on va retrouver
bien sûr
à la fin
dans les versets 7
et la parole
de Dieu
se répandait
c'est une phrase
qui va se répéter
à plusieurs reprises
au long d'actes
et ce que nous allons retrouver
c'est une église
menacée
qui prie
et qui prêche
qui prêche
et qui prie
et qui va réduire
sa fonction
sur la terre
en priant
prêchant
enseigner
les fondements
des apôtres
proclamer la parole
des dieux
vivre en communion
assidue
dans les temps
pour la prière
et dans les maisons
pour les partages de pain
c'est une église
qui vit
d'une manière
exagérément
simple
et qu'aujourd'hui
on a l'impression
que tous les experts
dans la croissance des vies
nous diront
ça ne marche plus
ça ne peut pas marcher
et c'est exactement
la manière
que Dieu choisit
car Dieu fait
les choix
non seulement
des fins
mais il a aussi
pourvu les moyens
et les moyens
par excellence
c'est prière
et prédication
c'est les progrès
de la parole
par les moyens
de la prédication
c'est la prédication
proclamée
dans la puissance
de Saint-Esprit
il n'y a aucun
substitut
l'arme secrète
qui a bouleversé
les mondes
qui a provoqué
cette explosion
de croissance
c'était prier
et proclamer
et nous
devons faire
confiance
à cette manière
de Dieu
de bâtir
son église
donc c'est très intéressant
quand on voit
plusieurs personnes
qui sortent
pour implanter
des églises
qui sont
très fatiguées
car pendant
un moment
dans les processus
ils doivent
s'écharger
d'énormément
de choses
qui sont très pratiques
pour Achère
en échanger
avec nous récemment
il a mis
beaucoup d'emphase
et dans sa
compréhension
aujourd'hui
ce qui serait
l'idéal pour lui
c'était d'envoyer
avec une équipe
d'implantation
un diacre
qui soit très capable
qui puisse décharger
dès le départ
les pasteurs
pour se consacrer
à ce qui même
dès le départ
sera la forme
la plus efficace
d'accomplir
la volonté
de Dieu
qu'il se consacre
à la prière
et à l'étude
des écritures
donc
nous devons
avoir
au coeur
la conscience
que nous devons
libérer
les anciens
les pasteurs
pour qu'ils puissent
se consacrer
à ceux
qui étaient appelés
et qui sont prioritaires
donc c'est
prier
et prêcher la parole
n'est pas
les seules choses
qu'ils font
mais c'est la principale
chose qu'ils font
c'est ce qu'ils font
tous les temps
c'est comme s'ils étaient
dans un poste
comment vous appelez
un français
quand les médecins
doivent être
en vigile
en garde
un garde
les pasteurs
ils ne sortent
jamais
des gardes
il est quelqu'un
qui
aussitôt
une nouvelle opportunité
de prêcher
ou d'enseigner
apparaît
il ne peut pas dire non
il y a quelque chose
qui prend son lieu
c'est quelqu'un
qui doit
faire attention
à son emploi
de temps
pour ne pas négliger
d'autres responsabilités
qu'il a
envers sa famille
ses enfants
car ils sont aussi
quelque part
un ministère
de la parole
pour lui
mais la réalité
c'est que comme disait
Marc Arthur
par rapport à ses passages
c'est que
la fonction
des pasteurs
c'est une vocation
en continu
qui demande
toute la vie
et il dit
des fois je suis fatigué
des fois j'aimerais
ne pas devoir prêcher
les dimanches prochains
mais ma vie
depuis 50 ans
c'est une chaîne
connectée
des dimanches
après dimanches
devoir préparer
des sermons
et prêcher
et prier
et des fois
c'est la parole
qui rénouvelle
et réchauffe mon coeur
des fois c'est la prière
qui rénouvelle
et réchauffe mon coeur
mais je suis obligé
car même si je ne voulais pas
il y a
ce poids qui pèse sur moi
cette vocation
cette compulsion
que nous n'avons pas
la capacité d'effacer
c'est l'appel de Dieu
c'est en tout temps
et donc
les diacres sont là
pour libérer
les anciens
mais ils sont là aussi
pour catalyser
et amplifier
les ministères des anciens
les diacres
devraient être là
pour penser
à comment nous pouvons
projeter davantage
la proclamation
de la parole
comment nous pouvons faciliter
il y a plusieurs
reprises dans l'histoire
des fois c'était
les livres
qui ont aidé
c'était
la presse
plus récemment
ce sont des recours
d'enregistrement
au Dieu
plus tard
vidéo
aujourd'hui internet
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans l'histoire de l'église
que ces choses là
c'est ça que
Poaché dit
je crois
qu'il y a un rôle
légitime
pour ces ministères
à l'église
mais c'est pas
aux pasteurs
d'être là
si quelqu'un
prend ta prédication
et met sur internet
c'est bien
mais la réalité
c'est que
c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on devrait s'occuper
qui devrait prendre
notre temps
donc la réalité
c'est que nous
nous devons considérer
en fait
c'est
la priorité
de l'église
et pourquoi
c'est car l'église
est une institution
spéciale
et spécialisée
les besoins
les plus profonds
de l'homme
ne peuvent être
résolus
à part
prédication
de la parole
et prière
les besoins
les plus profonds
de l'homme
n'est pas tout simplement
un peu plus
des divertissements
n'est pas
l'emploi
qu'il aimerait avoir
ou la promotion
ou les mariages
même les choses légitimes
qu'on aurait désiré
pour améliorer
notre vie
n'ont pas la capacité
de régler
les problèmes
principaux de l'homme
n'est pas lorsqu'ils
les veuves
n'ont pas à manger
les problèmes
principaux de l'homme
c'est le destin
éternel de nos âmes
c'est la mort
spirituelle
c'est cette condition
décrite par
Ephésia chapitre 2
esclave
de Satan
esclave du monde
esclave de la chair
de nos passions
incapables
de sortir
de cette condition
et aucune stratégie
humaine
n'a la capacité
de changer
cette condition
surtout lorsque
l'église
fait face
à des persécutions
aussi affreuses
ou des catastrophes
ou lorsqu'un membre
de l'église
perd quelqu'un
qui est très cher
pour lui
j'ai des filles
arriver chez lui
avec un ministère
des théâtres
ou des danses
et porter la consolation
ou proclamer
la vérité
la réalité
c'est que
la proclamation
de l'évangile
et la prière
est la seule manière
de sauver
les perdus
et édifier
les chrétiens
le seul remède
efficace
est la proclamation
de l'évangile
et donc ici
nous voyons
la préoccupation
sociale
l'église
va consacrer
des personnes
pour prendre soin
de ça
mais
c'est les textes
par excellence
qui nous empêchent
de penser à l'évangile
comme l'évangile social
comme si
une église
n'est qu'est pertinente
voir ce qu'elle fait
des ministères
des distributions
de nourriture
etc
c'est important
de prendre soin
surtout
des membres
de l'église
les plus démunis
ceux de la foi
comme l'a dit
et de ne jamais négliger
les peuples
qui puissent
croiser notre chemin
mais l'église
n'a pas été
une organisation
destinée par Dieu
pour régler
les problèmes
de la pauvreté
les pauvres
vous allez toujours
avoir avec vous
nous ne pouvons jamais
négliger
ce sont l'image
des dieux
mais la seule chose
que c'est qu'est l'église
qui puisse faire
c'est de régler
un problème
beaucoup plus radical
dans l'être humain
qui assure une vie
éternelle
de prospérité
et qui a la capacité
de changer
tellement la personne
dès sa source
que même
ses problèmes
des difficultés
par exemple
de trouver un emploi
ou de réorganiser sa vie
sera réglé
même dans ces mondes
les datas
les données
nous prouvent
que la manière
la plus pragmatique
d'améliorer socialement
la condition
de l'homme
c'est un nombre
plus grand
des personnes
qui se convertissent
car là
où les vrais réveils
ont passé
il y a eu toujours
des transformations sociales
des transformations
des vies
des changements
et donc la solution
c'est qu'on se paraisse
plus avec Christ
et naturellement
chaque membre
de l'église
ne pourra pas négliger
un pauvre
qui croise notre chemin
vous comprenez ?
et si
sa vie est transformée
par l'évangile
il va vivre
d'une telle manière
un acte réellement
prospéré aussi
donc
c'est l'argument
le plus
pragmatique
on voit les réveils
qu'on considère
en acte 2
37 à 45
où nous voyons
que l'église
volontairement
vendait ses biens
pour
sécuriser
ceux qui étaient
dans les besoins
et cela était
un fruit du Saint-Esprit
pas une imposition
une ordonnance
et donc
nous voyons ici
que la prière
vient juste avant
la parole
il faut dire un mot
sur ça
donc
dans la Bible
quelque part
la parole
précède la prière
car sans la parole
on n'est pas converti
et
avec la parole
on apprend
à prier
par contre
dans la vie pratique
du chrétien
des fois
la prière doit venir
avant la parole
et pourquoi ?
pour plusieurs raisons
déjà
car l'orthodoxie
toute seule
la doctrine correcte
n'est sur personne
il faut prêcher
la vérité
dans la position
de son sain
on ne peut jamais
oublier notre dépendance
les plus
un chrétien prie
et ne va pas dire
j'ai prié suffisamment
donc je vais
relaxer
j'ai déjà
ressuscité
que j'avais besoin
les plus
un chrétien prie
sensible
il est au fait
qu'il ne peut rien
faire de lui-même
les plus sensibles
il est
qu'il est
dans un besoin
encore plus grand
et il va avancer
le plus sensible
on est à la bataille
spirituelle
qui est autour de nous
active
tous les temps
et combien plus
on est insensible
à cette bataille
le plus on va prier
car on sait
que c'est impossible
pour nous
de faire les ossements
desséchés
devenir vivants
et c'est ça
l'appel de l'évangile
que les morts
reviennent à la vie
et aucune stratégie
humaine
ne va jamais
avoir cette capacité
et donc
la prière
elle vient
d'abord
quelque part
aussi
pour nous rappeler
que devant
la tentation
de ces contextes
que les hommes
les plus chargés
des choses spirituelles
s'échargent
des choses
les plus naturelles
de nous rappeler
en fait
que nos armes
sont les armes
spirituelles
certains disent aussi
que c'est peut-être
à cause du fait
qu'on perçoit
comment la chair
peut résister
plus à la prière
qu'à la lecture
de la Bible
donc des fois
c'est l'une des raisons
pour laquelle
on ne peut jamais
oublier
que nous devons
prier
constamment
sans prière
aucune chose
ne va se passer
et ces deux tâches
elles sont ensemble
donc des fois
on va penser
que l'une
peut être prééminente
en relation à l'autre
mais la réalité
c'est qu'elles ne sont
jamais séparées
car
quand on considère
la tâche
à laquelle
étaient consacrées
les anciens
la hauteur
de la discipline
et les types
de connaissances
qu'elles exigent
donc par exemple
les challenges
d'un ancien
d'un prédicateur
c'est de préparer
un nouveau serment
chaque dimanche
les privilèges
c'est qu'on pourrait
préparer un nouveau serment
chaque dimanche
dans les mêmes textes bibliques
car la Bible
est convencée
à l'étoiler
en même temps
humainement parlant
à plusieurs reprises
on a un peu
la crainte
de se dire
mais qu'est-ce que
je vais pouvoir apporter
de nouveau
le dimanche prochain
et donc la réalité
c'est que
pour ceux qui donnent
des leçons
ou des cours
à l'école
ou à l'université
bien sûr qu'ils doivent
progresser toujours
dans leur enseignement
mais des fois
il y a déjà
un programme
qui se répète
nous sommes devant
la mer
de toutes les sciences
étudiées à propos
d'un Dieu
infini
des vertus
d'un Dieu infini
d'un évangile
dont la gloire
est infinie
en considérant
que la connaissance
la plus importante
qu'on doit vous communiquer
vous enseigner
ce n'est pas
une connaissance
morte
ce n'est pas
un échange théorique
c'est une parole
vivante
c'est une exhortation
qui cherche
à nous conduire
non seulement
la connaissance
théorique de Dieu
mais une relation
avec Dieu
et donc
cette fraîcheur
pour que je puisse
arriver un dimanche
ou un vendredi
avec quelque chose
de réel
substantiel
et frais
à vous apporter
ça passe non seulement
par mon intellect
mais ça passe
par mon expérience
avec Dieu
c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin
des prières
et paroles
la cohérence
des vies aussi
sachant que nous sommes
tous pécheurs
et qu'il y a plusieurs reprises
en se sentent
disqualifiés
pour venir
prêcher l'évangile
à cause
de nos péchés
nous avons besoin
constamment
de maintenir une vie
car c'est la seule profession
où
la continuité
de la profession
dépend
de la conduite morale
!
et là en fait
si
nous ne sommes pas
en train de prier
faire attention
pour qu'on ne tombe pas
et d'étudier la parole
nous ne pouvons pas tenir
quand on considère
la bataille
les forces de l'ennemi
les challenges
de ramener
les morts à la vie
nous sommes
complètement
en dessous
voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul dit
qui est suffisant
pour ces choses
l'apôtre Paul
il n'était jamais
dans un poupitre
avec l'attitude
du grand communicateur
de nos jours
qui va s'habiller
comme un acteur
des rois lioud
avec
les cheveux
tous mêlés
et qui
raconte sa vie
son histoire
et des blagues
tous les temps
il disait
entre vous
j'étais en train
de trembler
en faiblesse
et tremblement
car il sait
qu'il sera
rédévable
du destin éternel
des âmes
qui s'exposent
à son enseignement
et donc la charge
qui pèse sur lui
c'est de dire
malheur à moi
si je prêche
par l'évangile
la description
biblique
montre
que cette vie
c'est une vie
ininterrompue
des consécrations
à la prière
et à la
prédication
de la parole
de Dieu
bien sûr
que certains passages
dans la Bible
nous donnent
cette notion
d'exception
des hommes
des dieux
qui doivent
faire
les tentes
ou comme
je vous ai cité
par exemple
les passages
d'acte 8
où
les peuples
les chrétiens
ils annonçaient
la parole
ils évangélisaient
et là c'est plutôt
la signification
des
je ne sais pas
si c'est bon
en français
des tagalere
c'est tout simplement
des parler
parler
conversation
partager l'évangile
et certains
utilisent ces passages
pour dire
que c'est une base
publique
pour les ministères
à temps partiel
mais ce n'est pas
ça le cas
là c'est juste
tous les peuples
qui portaient
la parole
et il y avait
toujours les fonctions
de ceux
qui allaient
proclamer la parole
donc la perception
des versets bibliques
qui nous disent
que c'est une tâche
incontinue
parce que
Paul va dire
en 1ère
et là
le focus pour moi
ce n'est pas de parler
de l'argent ici
ou du salaire
mais c'est tout simplement
des mêmes aussi
1ère 21
les seigneurs
ont ordonné
à ceux qui annoncent
l'évangile
de vivre de l'évangile
et donc pour plus
qu'une église
dans un processus
d'implantation
n'est pas les ressources
ou les moyens
l'homme des dieux
appelé
selon les paramètres
du nouveau testament
doit toujours considérer
et désirer
et aspirer
et sentir les poids
et la compulsion
d'au jour
où il ne peut pas dire non
aux opportunités
de prêcher l'évangile
malheur à moi
même quand ils sont
en vacances
quand on les découvre
et qu'on l'invite
ils doivent aller prêcher
on nous a appris
on ne demande jamais
une opportunité
pour prêcher
mais si l'invitation
est faite
ne réussite jamais
et des fois
quand on est fatigué
Dieu ouvre
une opportunité
d'évangélisation
et on ne peut pas dire non
et donc la réalité
c'est que
quand on considère
l'occupation
de ces hommes
ils étaient
100%
de leur temps
réveillés
et parfois
rénonçant
les sommeils
pour prêcher
l'évangile
dans la vie
d'une église
ça doit s'afficher
de cette manière
la prédication
de la parole
est la chose principale
et si
les personnes
ont d'autres demandes
ou d'autres attentes
envers les anciens
on doit
faire comme
pour
la chère
à donner
l'évangile
un jour
en disant
ok
donc tu veux
qu'ils fassent quoi
à l'église
qu'ils soient
là
pour régler
toutes les visitations
qu'ils doivent faire
qu'ils doivent
travailler combien d'heures
à l'église même
qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui sont les parties
administratives
qu'ils gèrent
etc
et après
ils montent dans les tableaux
les heures qui restent
en fait
pour faire
ces deux choses
c'est préparer
pour prêcher
et prier
donc tu sais
que ton enfant
il a un destin éternel
combien de temps
tu penses
que les pasteurs
devraient être dédiés
pour prier
pour les membres
de la communauté
combien de temps
tu penses
que les pasteurs
devraient s'y préparer
si l'enjeu
est d'une maladie
mortelle
éternelle
nous n'allions jamais
confier nos enfants
par exemple
à un médecin
qui n'a pas fini
ses études
qui ne connait pas
les domaines
de son enseignement
de sa profession
nous devrions
attendre
que l'homme des dieux
soit
comme Paul dit
à Timothée
un homme
qui
maîtrise bien
la parole
de la vérité
qu'il soit consacré
à la compréhension
et à l'enseignement
donc malheureusement
à cause du temps
je vais devoir
arrêter ici
les prochains aspects
que j'aimerais mettre
en lumière
c'est tout simplement
la participation
de l'assemblée
car
elle a réjoui
de la proposition
des apôtres
donc nous
on ne va pas délaisser
la parole
on va se consacrer
à la parole
et à la prière
et l'église
était dans la joie
heureuse
et l'église
qui a la possibilité
de libérer
ses pasteurs
pour se consacrer
à temps plein
à la parole
et à la prière
Dieu
dans ses plans souverains
s'il a décidé
qu'une église
grandisse
les moyens secondaires
qu'il va utiliser
c'est que la croissance
de cette église
et la croissance
de ses membres
sera toujours
proportionnelle
à combien
les hommes
qu'il a consacrés
pour l'office pastoral
prient
et combien
ils proclament
la parole
vous comprenez
et donc voilà
pourquoi
la tâche
des diacres
est la plus importante
ou la plus spirituelle
possible
quand on considère
la relation
harmonique
avec ce qui est
les rôles
des anciens
donc vous allez
comprendre un peu mieux
tout ce qui concerne
votre participation
dans ces choix
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que les résultats
c'est que pendant
que les diacres
servaient en table
les anciens
ou les apôtres
ont pu
servir
nourrir les âmes
c'est les mêmes termes
diaconia
pour les deux
l'un qui sert
les choses pratiques
et l'autre qui peut servir
les choses spirituelles
Amen
donc si quelqu'un
peut faire une prière
au concours